[Music]
i think she does feel ostracized a lot
because you know she does get a lot of
attention my daughter is good and and i
get that i understand that i go full out
like i always am so big
we want this really bad
hi connie you're very nice
i put her in dance because i always
wanted her to be in dance and that's
when we seen the fire come out of her
and we knew that it was a passion her
name's going to be well known they're
going to be like oh that's brooklyn all
right do you guys want to go buy your
moms so tomorrow we start dancing
we start getting ready for the
competition
the dance-off was awesome i was really
impressed by a lot of you but there was
one person that really stood out to me
and
that one person is
kinley
you are the lead of our very first group
dance all right
are you okay
i think it's the excitement the pressure
you know there's a lot at stake here
someone's going to get cut
at the end of this week i think i need
to get her to a doctor
i think she's upset because she feels
like she's bailing you no you're not
zero percent
just try to block everything out okay
and just try to think about you and your
mom right now so just stay
calm try to take a deep breath
should i take her to a doctor now
absolutely safety first well let's go
get it checked out
emily is one of my favorites hey
it's okay i want to do that so fast i
know you do we cannot lose her i need
her at the first competition i'm so
upset and took my dream to the case
[Music]
here we go one two three four sadie
wears our hand out on those walks there
we go one two three four five six it's
not a mess clap it's a one strong strong
it's not a party party party that's
messy we don't like messi okay we gotta
be clean it's clapping it's not that
hard you can do it all right
sadie i think you're a baton twirler
i think that's when your sparkle switch
turned on i don't know if dance is your
thing i don't know if you're ready for
all this this is hard i'm sorry today
we're saying goodbye to you and you know
what this is it's not a goodbye
and i'll see you later okay
i will see you again one day you are
very talented
you're going to go very far in life i
think it was a good
opportunity but
i don't think it was the right one for
me yet
but i feel like i will get the right one
soon
yep
we'll always be sadie fans
right you'll always be our friend and
you always have a special place in our
heart
[Music]